five four three two one
my friends and I we're from the San
Fernando Valley that flat stretch of
land on the other side of the Hollywood
Hills
but with actors waiters and wannabes we
can't afford to live in Los Angeles
young hustlers club I like it I like it
we're gonna be out of Valley by the end
of the summer look I have an idea this
is gonna be the best the best night of
your life
I'm DJ party sucks Ella's dead can't
play drunk in love absolutely not we got
to get out of here hi hi honey hi hi
you're James Reed right call me multiple
spin here regularly yeah hey no what are
you doing Saturday anything you can make
people dancing that's half the battle
Sam sincerely talented sounds have soul
build them from scratch you're not gonna
get anywhere using the same old sounds
at every other laptop DJ you
let's see whenever you guys are ready to
start making some real loot need a
holler at me this is the regular singing
don't you feel like there's a lot more
quality stuff we could be doing we
signed up for lifetime in real estate
you're not happy
life there gonna be things to finish you
will be tempting you can do about it I
think I'm going back to work for that
guy you're out of your mind what
happened to loyalty yeah you leave here
to take your crib anymore
any successful artists have this moment
but they stopped being an admirer and
they find their signature
I think I have something
this is the best part the moment before
it starts
a lot of beating hearts out there what's
up I'm Cole Carter
venez Ovitz right Ritesh call it super
Dean Dan's actor shite
when a globe - are better fed in
happiness Malibu coiffed